Really high winds now here in a typhoon in Tokyo!
I shouldn't be outside, but I am, because--
I look heroic.
These are typhoon winds, I tell ya!
Oh, here comes someone, hello.
Act more dramatic.
You're totally undercutting what I'm doing.
I'm going like this.
No, and you're just walking with coffee?
On a Starbucks run?
It's not Starbucks.
Get outta my shot!
Here comes a very brave young investment banker.
Get inside, you'll be killed.
Oh, thank you, thank you very much.
You're good man.
You went out of your way to make a snide comment.
Okay, release that water bottle so it looks dramatic!
That's it?
This is Conan O'Brien for Channel Four News,
saying we used to be Channel Seven News,
one day, day we'll be Channel Two News.
Back to you CNN.
This has been TBS.